- Well, Louann and Ramona,
there have been rumors that a
major cast shakeup is coming
to real Housewives of New York.
So how would you feel about that?
- Well, first of all,
you can't believe anything
you read, because--
- Girl you are talking, I know, I get it.
There's lies!
- But they do think we
could some definitely
some more cast members
I mean, if we come back,
I would definitely like to
see a lot more people come on
because I gotta hate somebody new.
(kelly laughing)
- Oh my God.
- And we're only five right now.
So, you know, we have
a small cast compared
to a lot of the franchises
so I think we need
a kind of a reboot,
and it's always nice to have, you know,
new people on the show also, you know?
Make new friends and experience
new personalities and--
- They're energizing us.
- And different energy, you know?
So I think it's a good thing.
- I could listen to you
talk all day, your voice--
- She has a great voice.
- [Kelly] She's, I'm like first of all--
- I have a good impersonation of her.
So ladies, how are you doing today?
- I mean, it's just the right amount
of like rasp and like the tone is so.
You should get into like apps,
like, you know, reading them.
- Well that's why I do
my cabaret, you know,
I'm doing my cabaret show.
- [Kelly] Oh my God. It's perfect.
- Yeah right? Thank you.
And coming from you that's
a major major compliment.
Thank you.
- I only sound cool like that
when I'm really sick,
I'm getting close now.
Like when I'm sick, I'm like,
oh, this is my Toni Braxton.
Like it's very low and I
can sing Unbreak My Heart.
And the only time I can.
- Well I love your
voice. I love your voice.
- Oh, thank you.
Thank you. I love Toni's as well.